pas là
derniers préparatifs avant le départ que
zico homme attendait depuis très
longtemps une parade naba en lot
président
oui la fondatrice des femmes au floride
pour trump n'a pas ménagé ses efforts
pour réunir le plus grand nombre de
bateaux possible sur la côte d'émeraude
des centaines d'embarcations venues de
partout en floride et des états voisins
tout aux couleurs de dans notre
démonstration force à deux mois des
élections est une fan de la première
heure idolâtre dans leur chambre depuis
près de dix ans à ses yeux les
démocrates représentent une grave menace
pour l'avenir des états unis le défilé
est un succès il a rassemblé selon les
organisateurs plus de 1500 bateau
l'occasion d'envoyer un message clair le
nord ouest de la floride
très conservateur reste fidèle à dans le
temps
[Musique]
la bataille électorale qui joue ici est
loin d'être anodine car avec son poids
démographique
la floride est de loin l'état pivot le
plus important est pour dans notre
chambre
c'est même essentiel impossible pour lui
de penser renouveler son bail à la
maison blanche sont gagnants en floride
aucun républicain ni est arrivé en prêt
de 100 ans
or depuis quelques mois les signes
inquiétants pour le trempe se
multiplient en floride
le scrutin est toujours très serré et se
joue souvent à moins de 1% à quelques
milliers de votes les indépendants et
non affiliés font souvent pencher la
balance
mais pour gagner ici dans mon trempe
doit d'abord garder ses appuis s'assurer
que les républicains fassent bloc
derrière lui
et difficile de faire plus républicain
que geof qui met depuis quatre ans ron
ne reconnaît plus son parti n'a rien ne
conserva sa morale de vie sa gestion de
l'économie
sa vision de la diplomatie autant
d'éléments qui selon lui ne disqualifie
alors pour la première fois de sa vie
ron philippe corse qui votera démocrates
et à former
[Musique]
mais la floride c'est aussi le paradis
des retraités un des états qui compte la
plus forte proportion d'électeurs âgés
les lecteurs généralement plus
conservateurs et ceux qui habitent au
fait les deux ne font pas exception
[Musique]
c'est un endroit à nulle autre pareille
une sorte de disneyland pour retraités
avec ses 54 terrain de golf
ces lacs aménagés et ses bâtiments qui
ressemble à des décors de cinéma
âge minimum 55 ans les enfants sont
interdites
tout le monde ici christelle il se
déplace en voiturette de golf
mais son soutien affiché aux candidats
démocrates lui vaut bien des insultes
malgré leurs allures paisible lévis les
deux sont le théâtre d'une bataille
électorale âprement discutés batailles
menées comme tout le reste ici en
voiturette de golf crise se sait très
minoritaire ici mais elle sent un début
de changement à cause entre autres du
coronavirus déjà 650 mille cas en
floride et douze mille morts
l'apparition progressive des masses qui
s'y révèle une inquiétude grandissante
la rue jaurès davis en tout 2 81 ans et
n'osent plus sortir de chez eux sans se
couvrir le visage tout deux républicains
ils vont voter contre dans notre
changement en bonne partie en raison de
sa gestion
des affections qui reste peut-être
marginal mais cristallerie en est
convaincu plus que jamais en floride
chaque vote compte cinq ans la prudence
reste de mise
il reste encore près de deux mois avant
l'élection
et d'ici là beaucoup d'eau pas encore
coulé sous les ponts
[Musique]